- Rumors are there was no music.
- [D Rock] I didn't use
the airport Gary music.
- Why would you not use the
airport Gary music when I'm
turning into airport Gary?
- [D Rock] I don't know.
- Oh, that's a good answer.
That would be the right answer, right?
And I appreciate the--
- [D Rock] I'm not going to bullshit it.
- Well, you tend to like to bullshit.
- [D Rock] I never bullshit.
- You like to bullshit for
a second here and there.
D rock, this is the
greatest moment of the show.
This is the only part I
will watch the show for.
It's your favorite time everybody.
As I turn into the greatest superhero
known in entrepreneur land.
I'm also the only superhero
in entrepreneur land.
For now.
I'm looking for my other
cast of characters so please,
in the comments section tell
me which character you're
going to be which is going
to compliment this universe
of entrepreneurial superheros
but it's that time again.
Cue the music, D Rock.
(dramatic music) Airport Gary.
This is the 002.
- [Man With Glasses] Yeah.
- Pretty cool right?
- It's beautiful, yeah I love that.
- [D Rock] It's pretty close
- It's similar, yeah.
(laughing)
I mean, that's the style I like.
You know what's funny, I'm
not obsessed with like.
I'm not obsessed with forcing
technology when people
aren't using it.
If Nike doesn't have people
using technology in their
sneakers, I surely am not
going to pull that off.
(laughing) You know what I mean?
- [D Rock] Yeah.
- To me, I like to react to
what's actually happening
verse force something
that I'd like to happen.
I think it's a crucial
mistake of most businesses
trying to force their
narrative or their ambitions
down the consumers' throat
instead of feeding what the
consumer is telling you what they want.
(mumbling)
What's that?
I think it comes from audacity and ego.
(multiple people talking in background)
From human behavior, from
people running companies who
think they are big time.
I'm never going to take the
end consumer's attention
for granted.
Bye.
- [D Rock] Had to be your first window.
- That's my first window selfie.
That's my first window
selfie, but not my last.
- How do you want to inspire people today?
- You know, it's funny I
don't really care about
anything other than getting
people to do, right?
Whether it's something I
say, whether it's my overall
optimism and energy, whether
it's an answer to a question,
whether it's my relentless
suffocation of excuses or
a tactic.
You know, the reason I think
I go very hard on stage is
cause I'm trying to find
as many different angle--
everybody responds to
something different, right?
It's not just high energy.
It's not just a thoughtful response.
Sometimes it's even more
subtle things like humility
of saying the customer is always right.
It's not about how, it's
can I get even one person to
fundamentally take advantage.
I mean look at what you
and I are doing right now.
We're live.
Do you know how much money--
There used to be a huge van
out there with a satellite.
I don't think people understand
how amazing the opportunity
is so I'm hopeful to inspire
or force somebody to try
something new.
- You are inspiring me right
now so that's very good.
- Thank you, thank you.
- Thank you so much for this
two questions and good luck
on stage.
- Thank you, by everyone.
- Thank you so much.
- Nice meeting you guys.
- You're welcome.
You're welcome (giggling).
A blog about to go on stage.
You know, just (giggle)
just such a ridiculous life
like so crazy to see
entrepreneurship put on this
pedestal.
I never thought I would have
screaming girl fans, D Rock.
- [D Rock] Outside a window, that's great.
- I mean the window selfie
(mumbling) just like
life's weird.
Good?
- [D Rock] Oslow, get ready.
The single best keynote in
the history of this wonderful
country is about to be given.
- [Announcer] Let's give
a big warm welcome to
Gary Vaynerchuk.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- That's very nice, thank you so much.
(crowd chanting Gary)
I think there's a lot of
misconceptions, assumptions,
curiosities, difficulties for
a lot of B to B marketers,
for a lot of entrepreneurs,
for a lot of consumer based
companies.
I think it's a very binary debate.
I really think that we're in
a place right now where you
either believe in what I think
is happening or you don't.
And I want everybody to
listen to that sentence
very carefully, not about
what's coming, that's what's
about to happen, what's happening
versus believing that or
not.
I think that people don't
understand how much they are going
to regret when they are older.
I also think a lot of
executives here are going to get
fired in six years for being
conservative even though
that's what their company's
telling them to do.
They are going to be the fall
guy and the fall gal when
the company starts faltering.
So, a bunch of people here
are going to be out of a job.
They think they're being smart
and a political animal and
they're going to get promoted,
but they don't realize that
the market is changing on
them and when everybody looks
at them and they were the
ones pushing bullshit because
the company wanted them to pull bullshit.
They're going to get fired and
I don't want that to happen
to them.
I'm trying to get them to
die on their sword instead
of somebody else's.
And I'm trying to focus on
getting them to tell the truth
instead of what they think
they need to do to get another
bonus this year.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
And the reason they are clapping
is they know how so true
what I just said was.
(audience laughing)
And your clapping yet
conflicted and I'm empathetic.
I don't think I'm cool.
I don't think you're bad.
I just wanna have these
conversations so you can be
thoughtful, right?
Like maybe it's time to
have the courage to say what
you actually believe because
let me tell you something
getting killed on somebody
else's thesis sucks.
You'd rather go down with yours.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
Of course.
- I'm Demillico.
I follow you since this moment last year.
I was like amazing.
- Thank you
- Can we just take a picture?
- Sure
So what's the question?
- My question is what should I do--?
- You either raise capital
- Yes, sir
- Or you start maximizing
even more margin and just be
patient.
- That's right.
- I mean like Wine Library,
we made no money the first
four years
- Yes, sir
- So from 23 to 27, there was nothing.
There was like no margin, none.
But enough, enough, enough
you keep reinvesting, you keep
reinvesting.
You just got make sure
you're making enough,
a little bit more, a little bit more.
That's all.
- So that's what I'll do
- Patience
- Very politely, thank you so much.
- You're welcome, take care.
- Pleasure to have you.
- Thank you
- Great
- Thank you.
Just had a nice chat with my dad.
That's always fun.
So I should always be
up to some shenanigans.
Some strategies.
(mumbling)
- I just caught up on more.
When you're an entrepreneur
and you own your own business,
you always have some level of anxiety.
With me, it's I talk about
eating shit last line of
defense, always on fire.
I'm always thrilled when I'm
in Europe and I give a speech
and I get off stage and for
the last 30 minutes I've looked
at every email and every text
and nothing's really on fire.
I'm in the best spirit right now.
This is a rare moment, a very
rare moment where nothing's
clearly on fire.
There's smoke, don't get me
wrong, there's always smoke, but
I'm in a funny zone right now.
I always like being on
the other side of things.
When you're ahead in your
day, and you're work is just
getting revved up.
That's why I'm always thinking
about London, you know,
because it's already in action, so.
The update is, I'm super
happy that I only have a bunch
of smoke situations and
nothing five alarm inferno.
- Can I get a picture with you?
- Sure, how are you?
- Good.
- I'm Mason.
- That's awesome, it's nice to meet you.
(mumbling)
- Nice.
- Awesome.
- Thank you so much.
- Great to see you.
Yep you know, fun fact for
a lot of you that don't know
this.
I post my own shit.
I reply as me.
It's me, yep it's really me.
And let me, let me actually
explain why it's really me.
Being a practitioner allows
me to be the best strategist,
allows me to be the best entrepreneur.
Like you have to do your own
shit, you don't outsource
the part that matters.
The part that matters to me is you.
Um, that's how I learn, that's how I know.
It's about listening.
I'm talking because I've
been doing so much fucking
listening in parallel.
Always and forever.
- I have made it.
It hasn't succeeded, yet.
And I'm just at the point
where I keep losing and losing
and I'm getting lost.
It's not complaining
or anything like that.
- Are you getting discouraged?
- (mumbling) I've been through
that and I've just decided
I'm just going to keep going
and going until I succeed
but basically--
- Dude, that's huge.
Why do you think I talk
so much about that?
- Yeah, so basically--
- So everyone wants to be
at number one and if you're
number three or seven, so
I'll give you a good piece of
advice, if you're smart
enough to get there watch and
you live here?
- No, I just moved to the
UK because my biggest fear.
- Great, great so you're in London.
You're in the UK.
You look at the landscape.
You make a list of 55 number
ones that you've decided.
You take a step back and
you watch and you say okay,
here's 55 number ones that I like.
And then you watch, it's
always watching, it's always
listening.
What do they need?
Because the biggest problem
about once you decide that
you're not a number one is
most people don't know how to
approach a number one.
(mumbling)
A number one is hard to penetrate.
A number one is a number one for a reason.
A number one doesn't need a lot of stuff.
A number one, if you try to
sell them the way you sell
everyone else, you lose
before you started.
So, I always say and I don't
know how much you've heard this
I don't always say, but often
I say you gotta watch when I
have something whether
it's a sneaker or a book.
D Rock, D Rock asked to make
a video for me five times on
email.
The first four times
I didn't even respond.
He didn't.
The amount of people that
have emailed me and said hey
you need to make more video content.
I normally charge 10,000.
I'll do it for you for 2,000.
Delete, delete.
So, he wanted to do it for
free, he had been watching my
content and knew how to make--
gave me, said some things
that made me think he could.
You know, asked five times
got his chance and then
delivered and then he built
and then stayed patient
when other people when--
So the way to hack a number
one is first you have to decide
which first number ones you like.
- Yep.
- Then you need to see what
he or she is into, what are
their weaknesses or what are
they talking about or how
are they acting then figuring
out is that something you can
bring to the table.
And so now you start
with 55, you get a read.
You're down to 12 that whatever
you think you're good at.
The fact that you've already
realized you're not a
number one is already you're
willing to be self aware.
- Of course yeah
- And then you attack
- Help sales
Just suck at sales (mumbling).
- Or you need a team that
already has sales taken care of.
Because number one
isn't necessarily sales.
- But can I run like another
three and just hire one.
- You could.
No, you could run, you
could create a partnership
50/50 with somebody that's
great as sales and you're
great at whatever you
think you're great at.
- Yeah
- Or you can work for an
organization where you can learn.
But it's don't just assume
that a number one needs to be
great at sales.
Some number ones are not
great at sales, they're great
at management, they're great
at structure, they're great
at branding.
I would argue that I'm not great at sales.
I'm so good at branding
that it trickles into sales
but I don't love asking people.
I'm very uncomfortable with it.
I don't love it.
I can do it.
I've done it.
I'm probably good at it.
But, I'd far prefer it come
to me then me come right?
Cause that's how you really sell.
So, those are some thoughts.
- Yeah
- It's all self awareness brother.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- It's all self awareness,
like of course--
(mumbling)
I could have spent the
last, I mean I understand
finances but compared to
my brother, my CFO, my dad,
Steven Ross, I am not as good as them.
I don't understand the tax code,
the angles, there are a lot
of things where I lose
money but I'm okay with that
because there's a lot
of things I'm great at.
It's important to understand yourself.
When you are tricking yourself
you get into a bad place.
That's why so many people are upset.
They want to be something
instead of figuring out
who they are.
They want to be something,
but that's the problem.
They aspire to be something
they've subjectively decided
is cool verses, like listen,
you know how scared I am that
my brand getting big and
everybody and I don't want
anyone to be me.
I'm very unique in my
background and upbringing.
There can be people that are me.
I want them to be like me in
the fact that I'm fully me
and then you need to be fully you.
The other thing is too many
people think that, people
don't understand that
money is not that play.
Like, I say it all the time.
137,000 is a ton, 50,000.
You can have a very happy life for 50,000
especially if you're at
peace in your mind and you
love being a janitor,
a secretary, an admin,
people are getting confused.
They are getting confused.
They want stuff that doesn't matter.
It's a whirlwind.
Whoa.
I have no idea how I.
I don't know how I did.
- [D Rock] That we're keeping.
- Of course we're keeping
that's the best part of this
whole vlog.
I didn't drop it.
Good day so far going to
an influencer meet up and
then I'm going to sleep for
two hours and watch the Jets
stomp the Bills and then
we've got a long day tomorrow.
Copenhagen, Moscow, LA, four
cities in Australia, it's
pretty crazy out here.
Then we got this group,
weird art freaking us out.
Watch this.
She's about to scare the shit out of you.
There it was.
Yep, they move.
Yeah, build the biggest
building in town without
tearing down everyone else's building.
I think that that's a
very big thing for me.
I've always started saying
things like winners win.
You're not going to stop a winner.
I'm just surprised by how much
time and energy people spend
on trying to make somebody
they're competing with like
lose by them talking
bad behind their back.
You know, that's how I'm winning.
You know I have a lot of
competitors who spend their
entire dinner with a
client talking about me.
(groovy music)
That's when you win.
Like I'm not worried about
anybody else and so my weirdly
hope that everybody, I'm
pumped that Chris Soca made
more money when we
invested at the same time.
He deserved it.
He was more right.
I don't begrudge that.
I applaud it.
If anyone beats me ever,
and as long as it's fair,
well then I think that's the best.
It keeps me grounded, hungry,
and I also am genuinely
happy for somebody else.
I, look, there's so much
money and opportunity in the
system, nobody is stopping
you from getting yours.
If you think some guy or some
gal is winning and that's
coming out of your pocket, you suck.
If I can create successful
entrepreneurs and they create
successful entrepreneurs
like I, I think I'm putting
such good into the world.
I think you become a platform.
I think you can't be a platform
when you're bad because
you're selfish.
You're closed by nature,
but I feel like I'm open
source entrepreneurship.
I'm free.
And I'm putting out my
best shit, and I'm great.
best shit daily for free.
And so in a weird way I'm
more similar to open source
like I'm not keeping my best
ideas to myself so I can keep
the money.
I'm trying to empower.
I want people to win.
Jordan, right?
I wanted Jordan to be successful
and now he's a successful
fitness personality and
that helps other people and
dit dit dit dit dah.
(soothing music)